speaking of gaijin car though have you
guys ever used the gaijin card
in like funny situations should we
explain what the gaijin card is
sure you should probably go for it go
for it i mean i'm sure everyone knows
what the gaijin card is right but
basically the gaijin card
is gaijin means yeah in japan japanese
but
the guys playing the gaijin card
basically means you get away with [ __ ]
that japanese people wouldn't be able to
get away with in japan
but they forgive you because you're
supposed to be like a mindless foreigner
i mean yeah
i try not to actively like take
advantage of it i feel like it's not
fair of me to like use
you know being a foreigner yeah you know
because everyone goes through the same
struggles right life's hard enough
but i mean there's some stuff like
apparently you're not supposed to eat
and walk here right
yeah yep i i do that i don't like if i
if i have like 10 minutes to get to my
train i haven't had breakfast yeah i'm
grabbing that sandwich and eating it
like
i don't throw my [ __ ] away i don't make
a mess so i'm like you know it's fine
yeah i always wonder that that
then why is it that a lot of convenience
store food is so perfectly packaged for
on-the-go right i know
right and it's like but you can't eat it
on the go though onigiri just
that that's that's basically a rice
sandwich yeah that's that's meant to be
eaten as you're walking along but yeah
no you you want to do no one gives me
looks or anything or anything like that
it's just uh
i i'm told i'm not supposed to do this
but [ __ ] i'm gonna do it anyway but the
stuff i wouldn't dare do i like playing
i like doing the reverse gaijin card i
like playing the gaijin card and then
immediately after i've committed
the act just bust out the japanese
psych reverse uno
can you give us an example of a
situation uh so an example of a
situation i'm trying to think
what would be i mean you know something
like that right like not allowed to eat
on the go like not allowed to eat on the
train for example
where you know uh i would you know as
you said like sometimes i'm busy and
sometimes i gotta get something down
before i catch the train
so i would eat on the go and people
would kind of you know just
be like whatever um but then what i like
to do just to [ __ ] with people is
i i like to i finish the food
and then just just because i love seeing
people's reactions to this
i finish the food and then i pretend to
get in a phone call and i just talk in
japanese as loud as i can
just because seeing the confused phases
of japan
like is he gaijin or is he not guided
i don't even know anymore is my favorite
[ __ ] past time i've i've done
the exact same thing but just when i'm
in thailand yeah and you know when
you know when people gossip about you in
in their native tongue you don't know
they don't know that you understand them
and you just want to flex on them to be
like
[ __ ] i know exactly what your mother
[ __ ] says
you better watch yourself [ __ ]
oh dude i've had so many experiences
like that especially when you're outside
of
tokyo where you're obviously not used to
the foreigners um
i was in the supermarket once uh with my
sister we were like really really young
maybe like i was playing maybe like nine
or ten years old oh wow um and we were
just in the
the the aisle that has all like the
snacks and stuff right because
japanese snacks are like the [ __ ]
best and we were just picking stuff out
and there was this kid probably around
the same age as me
who was just like staring at us from
like down the aisle
obviously because we looked foreigner
right yeah he'd obviously never seen a
foreign kid in here
yeah so he was just staring and then his
other friend came up
and i could clearly hear that they were
like oh look at these [ __ ] foreigners
like
it was those nine-year-olds yeah
xenophobia fast yeah
legit they were like oh man look at
these foreigners that looks so weird
like you know there's something along
that yeah yeah yeah and i heard
everything and i'm just like oh you
[ __ ] prepare for my prepare for my
backhand
nine year old backhand i've never decked
a nine-year-old before but today could
be the day
yeah you're pushing it i've never
close-lined anybody but man
you guys are just perfect distance so
just to [ __ ] with them i was like oh
sh my nine-year-old man was like i'll
show them
so i i sorry out loud to my sister
i said in japanese i said have you
finished selecting which one you want
and i think my sister quickly picked up
on it too because i think she overheard
it yeah so she was like all right i'll
play your game
and back in japanese she was like yeah
i've almost finished um
and then she busted out this really like
specific japanese reference and from my
periphery
just i'd never seen like a nine-year-old
with like a pog champ face in my life
but it was just like
they're like what you would have thought
these kids would have seen like the face
of god like they were just like
oh my god what the [ __ ] is that and just
to [ __ ] with them even further
when we finished selecting our [ __ ] i
purposely went towards the kids
and as i passed by i busted out a
sumimasen
and that was just like the finishing
blow like that might as well
i just clotheslined them with my words
right right you having a death note ask
encounters
i [ __ ] care don't eat the [ __ ] out of
that that's